HAS GOAL UP IN SMOKE IF SOME
RINKY DINK ROOSKY IN MOSCOW
COULD SWING IT FOR YOU.
AT ANY
IS ANY
ISN'NY
ISN'TY
ISN'T JUST TEXT MESSAGES.
THE FBI'S FAIN MA'AM MUST
RELIANCE ON THE TRUMP
DOSSIER IS DOING A GOOD JOB
AS WELL.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN RON
DESANTIS OF FLORIDA SAYS
THAT USE OF THE DOSSIER
UNDERMINES THE BASIC
LEGITIMACY OF THE FBI'S
WARRANT TO INVESTIGATE THE
AND CONGRESSMAN DESANTIS
JOINS US NOW.
THIS IS A VERY INTERESTING
LEGAL POINT YOU MADE.
IF THIS DOSSIER WAS THE
PRETEXT FOR THE ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION, IT'S A KIND
OF ALMOST ABSURD FRUITS OF
THE POISONOUS TREE THING IN
THAT IT'S NOT -- IT'S NOT A
LEGIT MATS PRETEXT FOR AN
INVESTIGATION; IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> YEAH.
JUST THINK ABOUT WHERE THIS
PARTY.
THEY PAID MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO LAW FIRM WHO THEN
LAUNDERED IT TO FUSION GPS.
SO HAVE YOU FUSION GPS
WAS MORE OF A COVER TO MAKE
IT LOOK LIKE AN INTELLIGENCE
PRODUCT.
BUT TO THIS DAY, THE FBI
CAN'T VERIFY ANYTHING IN IT
OTHER THAN ONE PERSON
ASSOCIATED WITH TRUMP
TRAVELED TO RUSSIA AT SOME
POINT, SO THIS STUFF IS
BOGUS.
IT'S FAKE NEWS.
AND YOU EXPECT THAT KIND OF
STUFF TO BE GENERATED IN THE
COURSE OF A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
BUT IF THAT IS PRESENTED TO
THE FBI, AND THEN THEY ARE
TAKING THAT UNVERIFIED
DOSSIER AND LAUNCHING A
FEDERAL COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION WITHOUT
ANYTHING MORE, TO ME, THAT
RAISES SOME SERIOUS
QUESTIONS.
AND WAS IT PETER STRZOK WHO
WAS INVOLVED?
REMEMBER, THE KEY TEXT
TRUMP CAN'T WIN AND STRZOK
SAYS I DON'T THINK THE FIB
CAN TAKE THAT RISK WE NEED
AN INSURANCE POLICY BASIC
LIVE AGAINST TRUMP'S
WALLS THE DOSSIER SUBSEQUENT
INVESTIGATION HE REFERENCED
IN THOSE TEXT MESSAGES.
>> Mark: WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
HERE IS IT COMES BEFORE A
CAESAR JUDGE WHO ISN'T AN
EXPERT IN INTELLIGENCE
MATTERS BUT IT'S GOT THE
FBI, KIND OF GOT AN MI 6 IN
PREMATTER BECAUSE THE SPOOK
APPEARS TO HAVE CREDENTIALS.
DOCUMENT IF LAID BEFORE A
JUDGE.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> WELL, THAT'S THE
QUESTION.
WE HAVE ASKED THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, THE FBI, TO GIVE
US THE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
POSSESSION.
DOSSIER?
DID THEY USE IT AS THE BASIS
TO GET THESE FISA WARRANTS?
AND THEY BASICALLY REFUSED
TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION.
PRODUCE THIS TO THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, BUT
THAT'S THE QUESTION AND
HERE'S THE THING, MARK, IF
THE ANSWER TO ALL THOSE
QUESTIONS WAS KNOW, THOUGH
WILL SAY NO, THE FACT THEY
ARE HAVEN'T TO MEECH RAISES
SERIOUS QUESTIONS.
>> Mark: THEY HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT THIS THING FOR A
YEAR AND A HALF NOW AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE COOKED IT
UP IN A FEW WEEKS.
THEY HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
CORROBORATE ANYTHING EXCEPT
SOME GUY AT SOME POINT GOT
ON A PLANE TO RUSSIA.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT HE DID
ONCE HE GOT OFF THE PLANE IN
RUSSIA.
HOW MANY MORE MONTHS OR
YEARS DO THEY NEED TO
SUPPOSEDLY ATTEMPT TO
CORROBORATE THIS NONSENSE?
>> LOOK, I THINK IT'S TIME
TO PUT UP OR SHUT UP.
THIS WHOLE THING STARTED,
STARTED THE COUNTER
INTELLIGENCE.
WHEN MUELLER GOT APPOINTED,
BIG MISTAKE.
PROSECUTOR ON TOP OF A
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
AND HOW GOOD OF APPEAR
INVESTIGATION THAT WAS,
OBVIOUSLY, THERE IS A LOT OF
CONCERN ABOUT THAT.
BUT, THERE'S NEVER BEEN A
CRIME IDENTIFIED HERE.
YOU CAN BELIEVE THAT RUSSIA
TRIED TO HACK DIFFERENT
PEOPLE'S EMAIL ACCOUNTS, BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE
WAS A CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY
WITH TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN.
AND THERE HAS NEVER BEEN
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION, THEN I
THINK WE NEED TO MOVE ON.
I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
AND I THINK THE RESULT IS